that's why i questioned if it was a
prequel yeah
yeah because i'm like wait a minute i
read the log line
it says it takes place years following
the and that's probably what they're
talking about
right like they don't know what we know
about how you got made because we read
about the events of the first movie and
we're here doing the exact same [ __ ]
today
[Music]
what is going on reject nation greg and
john here
today as we are talking with you at 7 00
a.m
the loki reaction is exporting i don't
know if this video is going up first or
second but the don't breathe 2
trailer is actually here and once we
heard
that it was coming out at 7 00 am all
plans
changed we found ways to fill that
everything we were going to do for
patreon and all additional
filming and editing powered through the
night and loki is exporting right now
more like don't sleep don't sleep
olivia that's what olivia told me
olivia's olivia's just sleeping there
right now yeah not for much longer
just waking up right now while we react
loudly to this horror movie
i like the first don't breathe i liked
it a lot yeah now let's see if we'll
like the trailer for the movie that's
not
directed by fetty alvarez
[Music]
[Music]
he got his creepy baster daughter
shadow
so
[Laughter]
what do you want you're coming with us
kid
he's a hero now
[Applause]
this is a this is a prequel
that's some jigsaw [ __ ]
he's like the protagonist this is
awesome
they've made him daredevil serial killer
whoa interesting
look whoa i did not expect it
to go down that path he got
what he wanted and now he has to fight
to protect it no it's definitely a
sequel it's definitely
my mind got a little bit confused for a
brief second been up for almost 24 hours
excuse me
because i was trying to remember some of
the back story first yeah but damn he
got what he wanted he got his daughter
and he winds up in the exact same
situations people becoming it
except this time it's yeah it's not to
get his money it's like
kidnap her that is so funny
yeah it's a very fascinating pitch we're
sitting here going
is that your turkey baster daughter is
this like a totally
messed up scenario but also kind of
endearing because you guys clearly care
about each other
like what is happening here but then
also yeah he does
look like he's gonna become the liam
neeson protagonist just keeping people
from taking his daughter it's funny
because it's the exact same plot
it's so cool yeah what do you mean
it's pretty much i'm not disagreeing
with it's
the exact same plot that's
same ridiculous plot of three burglars
breaking in no you're in my territory
now and they've
heightened like the slasher vigilante in
the shadows
equality to him yeah it's just a flip in
perspective the difference is
there's a save the cat quality to him
because this is a girl he's protecting
her and he's the protagonist
as opposed to the burglar's other
protagonist
and he's the secret villain they didn't
expect to be a villain
so this is just now he's just the guy
they shouldn't have messed with
it's it's so interesting to me it kind
of reminds me of like the
psycho franchise you know how like
norman bates was always the villain but
then he becomes like the main character
yeah yeah exactly i kind of wish they
came up with something that's a little
bit more original to be honest
a different plot like why'd you go with
exactly
three burglars again breaking
yeah part of me is like oh man like
there's the naturally flowing sequel
here but part of me kind of wishes that
yeah maybe the setting was at least a
bit different maybe it was like an
open space scenario instead of another
home invasion scenario
that's why i questioned if it was a
prequel yeah yeah because i'm like wait
a minute i read the log
line it says it takes place years
following the and that's probably what
they're talking about
right like they don't know what we know
they don't know
about how you got made because we read
about the events of the first movie and
we're doing the exact same [ __ ] today
so we're not trying to steal money we're
trying to steal you in the same vein of
how halloween kills gave me the vibe
of i'm just excited to watch michael
myers mess some people up now
in this very heightened violent thriller
yeah yeah that was what i walked away
feeling here
i'll admit though a bit disappointed in
other there's other
there's things about it that i really
liked i find it very just
incredibly amusing that they did the
same exact
but there's also something disappointing
and well this doesn't look
scary at all this doesn't looks remember
that first it looks more like an action
movie remember the first trailer
just like oh [ __ ] terrifying damn
oh my this evil dead guy just does these
menacing movies yeah
because now the villain is the pure is
the he's the hero of this story he's the
protagonist i mean hero's not the right
choice of words but he's certainly the
protagonist
his skills are going to become the the
thing that makes you feel
safe rather than threatened throughout
the movie yes you're underneath these
circlers ancient
it's an interesting experiment i think
for your sequel
but it would be more compelling if it
wasn't just the same plot
maybe there are surprises they don't
want to put in the trailer i like i
could see how this could turn out to be
a surprisingly
you know lean mean and clever sequel but
i could also see how it's just kind of
like an
action rehash of don't breathe i do
feel like having jane levy's presence in
the first movie does something to ground
it where it's like it's mostly the
stephen lang show now
yes like none of the other burglars are
people i really recognize
you had to cheer for this guy who had
the turkey pastry
i don't think it's funny for the right
reasons yet those funny reasons are were
making me want to watch this
it's yeah it's like i don't i there
are so many things to think about this
and i just
yeah need to see the movie now i don't
know which way
this is gonna go what did you guys think
of this trailer at least they made it
out of detroit this is why we really
stayed awake it wasn't to
work to get up loki it was or to get
ahead it was
for this it was for don't breathe to
breathe harder
breathe harder to breathe
two breaths or the real reject good job
subscribe click the bells and uh
hit likes i'll see you soon